das ist ein riesen Fortschritt endlich
bereit für den Dauerbetrieb nach einer
längeren Umbauphase des Greifswalder
Forschungsreaktor Wendelstein 7x können
endlich neue Plasma Experimente
gestartet werden das große Ziel Plasma
für längere Zeiträume zu produzieren und
so den Dauerbetrieb zu demonstrieren und
tatsächlich sind in Greifswald in
letzter Zeit große Fortschritte erzielt
worden wird die Kernfusion Technik jetzt
bald Realität Clixoom science & future
bis dreimal pro Woche spannendes Heinz
Videos abonniert den Kanal und aktiviert
die Glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
los geht
herzlich willkommen ganze 600 wasserkühl
Kaiserin tin der vergangenen Zeit in der
Greifswalder Anlage zur plasmaerzeugung
eingebaut worden das große Ziel
Fusionswelle wandsitz Plasma soll anders
als bisher nicht nur für Sekunden
sondern für eine halbe Stunde erzeugt
werden das ist ein riesen Fortschritt
das ganze findet im Rahmen weltweiter
Entwicklungsarbeit zur Kern als mögliche
Energiequelle der Zukunft Stadt bei der
Kernfusion Technik stellt man quasi
etwas außerirdisches auf der Erde nach
die Kraft der Sonne Atomkerne werden zum
verschmelzen gebracht so dass Energie
gewonnen wird im besten Fall wenn der
Plan denn dann eines Tages mal aufgehen
sollte könnte ein kernfusionskraftwerk
eine Unmenge an Energie produzieren
manche glauben sogar dass damit alle
Energieprobleme auf unserer Erde gelöst
werden könnten und auch wenn es bei der
Kernfusion Technik noch viele offene
Fragen gibt am Ende winkt im besten Fall
tatsächlich eine Kernfusion die
umweltverträglich sauberen Strom
produziert damit könnte man sogar den
weiter steigenden Energiebedarf der Erde
decken solch ein Kraftwerk wäre zudem
Klima und umweltfreundlich und nicht nur
dass die Kante sonst Technik ist
deutlich ungefährlicher als die aktuelle
Atomspaltung in Kernkraftwerken hier
kann es zu einer super gefährlichen
Kettenreaktion kommt die Unmengen an
radioaktiver Strahlung freigesetzt bei
einem Fusionsreaktor kommt die Reaktion
bei einem Unfall zum Erliegen
und die radioaktiven Stoffe die
entstehen besitzen eine Halbwertszeit
von Jahrzehnten und nicht von
Jahrmillionen die Kernfusion wäre
dahingehend also ein riesiger
Fortschritt und jetzt kommen neue Infos
aus Greifswald in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
langfristig soll hier der Dauerbetrieb
demonstriert werden die Ergebnisse
könnten Forschungsteams weltweiter bei
ihren Plänen weiterhelfen ein Kraftwerk
zu entwickeln indem letztendlich
elektrischer Strom gewonnen wird
Wendelstein 7x ist also ein reiner
Forschungsreaktor mit dem man
herausfinden möchte ob ein Ziel arator
ein für ein Fusionskraftwerk geeigneter
Reaktortyp ist denn das ist das Ziel vom
Wendelstein 7x es sollen alle
Vorarbeiten für den Bau eines Kraftwerks
dieses Stellarator Typs geleistet werden
es ist also entscheidend wie man in
Greifswald vorankommt also wie und wie
realistisch sind die Ziele die mit der
Hilfe dieses Forschungsreaktor erreicht
werden soll und vor allem wie schnell
wird man hier die Ziele erreichen
Wendelstein 7x gilt als eine der
modernsten vor öffnungs Anlagen in
diesem Bereich der Reaktor bei
Greifswald bei der Vergangenheit schon
mehr als erfolgreich wir haben hier
öfter darüber berichtet Ende 2015 hatte
das Institut mit der Anlage das erste
Plasma erzeugt mehr als tausend
Experimente folgten und Elektronen
Temperaturen von bis zu 100 Millionen
Grad Celsius und John Temperaturen von
bis zu 20 Millionen Grad Celsius konnten
erreicht werden erst im August diesen
Jahres wurde in Greifswald ein
entscheidendes Etappenziel verzeichnet
die Wissenschaftler und
Wissenschaftlerinnen hatten den Magnet
Käfig in dem das Fusion Plasma
eingeschlossen werden soll in dieser
Anlage so optimiert dass
Energieverluste minimiert werden die
Bauart dieser speziellen Versuchsanlage
wird Stellarator genannt und erfüllt
seitdem eine wichtige Voraussetzung und
künftig einmal als Kraftwerk realisiert
zu werden von einem weiteren wichtigen
Typ der Fusion Son Lage Tokamak genannt
unterscheidet sich der Stellarator in
der Art und Weise wie das Magnetfeld
erzeugt wird mit dem das über 100
Millionen Grad Celsius heiße pulsions
Plasma eingeschlossen werden ein
entscheidender Nachteil des Stelle
Rathaus war bislang das viele Teilchen
entweichen konnten und somit ein enormer
Energieverlust stattfand die Verluste
wachsen mit steigender plasmatemperatur
so stark dass ein Kraftwerk sehr groß
und teuer sein müsste um unterm Strich
Energie zu liefern die Wissenschaftlerin
und Wissenschaftler des
Max-Planck-Instituts für Plasmaphysik in
Greifswald haben im vergangenen Sommer
aber den Magnet Käfig vom Wendelstein 7x
so umgestaltet dass daraus deutlich
weniger Teilchen entweichen und damit
viel weniger Energie verloren geht als
in früheren Stelle Radtouren in der
Pressemitteilung des
Max-Planck-Instituts heißt es dazu damit
ist mit Wendelstein 7x auch ein Schritt
hin zu einer Anlage gelungen die mehr
Energie erzeugen kann als für den Magnet
Anschluss und die Heizung des Plasmas
nötig ist laut der Greifswalder
Forscherinnen und Forscher sind die
Einbußen somit soweit reduziert dass ein
solcher Stellarator praxistauglich
werden könnte um die Güte des Plasmas zu
analysieren wird das Fusionsprodukt aus
Plasma Dichte der Energie Einschluss
Zeit und der Temperatur genau ins Visier
genommen diese Werte offenbaren dann
Bina eine solche Anlage einem brennenden
also Energie erzeugen passmark kommt der
große Vorteil des Generators ein
Dauerbetrieb ist möglich anders als beim
Tokamak hier wird gepulster Strom
eingesetzten das Plasma muss immer neu
gezündet werden denn noch die
Herausforderung der Kerwe sonst Technik
sind kaum in Worte zu fassen wir sind
mehr als gewaltig denn das Plasma musst
auf mehr als 100 Millionen Grad Celsius
aufgeheizt werden es wird von riesigen
Magneten gehalten denn das Plasma ist
elektrisch leitend und seine Teilchen
bewegen sich noch freier als die
Teilchen im Gas die Greifswalder
Magneten werden auf dem - 270 Grad
Celsius heruntergekühlt alleine das
Abkühlen dauert knapp zwei Monate somit
sollen sie nach dem Einschalten kaum
Energie verbrauchen bisher sind alleine
in die Anlage 400 Millionen Euro
geflossen wenn die Walz und Kosten wie
etwa Personal dazu gerechnet werden ist
man schon bei an 3000000000 Euro
angelangt im Vergleich zum Mieter in
Südfrankreich ist das nichts denn die
Anlage dauert ein Tokamak Reaktor hat
schätzungen zufolge bereits mehr als 20
Milliarden Euro gekostet in vier Jahren
soll sie dann erstmals in Betrieb gehen
hier könnte dann irgendwann die große
Premiere stattfinden so die Hoffnung der
Wissenschaftlerin und Wissenschaftler
wenn denn dann erstmals mehr Energie
erzeugt als Herr reingesteckt wird in
Wendelstein was vor drei Jahren 2018 das
erste mal soweit ist die Voraussetzung
dafür für besonders lange Zeit
aufrechtzuerhalten den Fachleuten war es
gelungen ein Plasma 100 Sekunden lang zu
erhalten das große Ziel in Greifswald
schon bald soll Fusionswelle Warentest
Plasma eine halbe Stunde lang erzeugt
werden und das wäre ein absoluter
Durchbruch doch genau dazwischen liegen
technisch und physikalisch gesehen
Welten so der Leiter des Wendelstein 7x
Thomas Klinger in einem Interview mit
der dpa um dann von einer halben Stunde
in den Dauerbetrieb zu kommen nein ist
dann vor allem wirtschaftliche Aspekte
die zu beachten sind um einen
Dauerbetrieb zu erlangen und zu
demonstrieren erfolgte seit zwei Jahren
2019 ein größerer Umbau unter anderem
wurde die Anlage um 600
wasserkühlkreislauf weiter jetzt sind
diese Arbeiten weitestgehend
abgeschlossen und im September 2022 soll
dann endlich das nächste Plasma in
Greifswald erzeugt werden dann wird auch
der halbstündige Dauerbetrieb in Angriff
genommen ein längerer Dauerbetrieb ist
wohl nicht umzusetzen denn dafür fehlt
in Greifswald ein typisches Kraftwerks
Merkmal die Kühltürme möglicherweise
könnte ein erstes Kraftwerk in der
zweiten Hälfte dieses Jahrhunderts kommt
davon geht beispielsweise der Leiter von
Wendelstein 7x Thomas Dinger aus doch
längst nicht alle sind der Kernfusion
positiv gegenüber eingestellt die Kritik
die Kernfusion kommt viel zu spät zu
spät für den Klimaschutz für den es
bereits jetzt oder besser noch gestern
Lösung geben muss so sieht es
beispielsweise die Energieexperten des
Deutschen Instituts für Wirtschaft
Claudia Kemfert wir brauchen jetzt
Lösung für den Klima viele Studien
weisen zu Recht darauf hin dass sie
Zukunft bei den erneuerbaren Energien
liegt denn die können und müssen schon
jetzt gebaut werden um die geplante
Klimaneutralität in der Europäischen
Union bis zum Jahr 2050 zu erreichen
dazu kann die Kernfusion wohl sicher
nicht beitragen Thomas Klinger und die
anderen Wissenschaftlerin und
Wissenschaftler die in der Kernfusion
eine große Chance sehen sind ganz andere
Meinung der wird froh sein über jede
Option ja auch wenn erneuerbare Energien
wichtig sind sein nicht garantiert dass
sie perspektivisch die Energieprobleme
der wachsende Weltbevölkerung lösen
können vor allem für die Versorgung von
Megastädten sei die Kernfusion eine
große Chance dazu Thomas Klinger da
einfach 56 dicke Kraftwerke rundherum
setzen Ruhe im Karton sprich in der
entfernten Zukunft könnte sie uns helfen
Energie Probleme zu lösen in der sehr
weit entfernten Zukunft selbst heute
geborene Generation dürften das aber
nicht mehr erleben Kernfusion neuer
Rekord im Forschungsreaktor Wendelstein
7x
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren bis
dann bleib dran